I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了“终极办公室重温”播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。
Hi! Hello, Miss. How are you? I'm good. I'm good, too. I didn't sleep great last night, but I have a weird amount of energy. I think we're in the loopy zone, because I have the same thing. All right.
嗨！哈喽，小姐。你好吗？我很好。我也很好。我昨晚没睡好，但我有一种奇怪的精力。我觉得我们进入了迷糊区，因为我有同感。好吧。
Well, today we're going to be talking about moving on part two. It is season nine, episode 17, written by Graham Wagner and directed by John Favreau. Here is your summary. Andy retaliates against Aaron and Pete by summoning their exes to the office under false pretenses. Toby is going to finally confront the convicted Scranton Strangler. He wants to tell him, I think you're innocent. Pam makes a decision about her future in Philly, and Dwight and Angela have a special moment of connection while caring for Aunt Shirley. And now I have some news that I could not be more excited to share. I'm telling you, if you build it up too much, it's going to disappoint. up too much, it's gonna disappoint.
今天我们要讨论的是“继续前行”第二部分。这是第九季第 17 集，由格雷姆·瓦格纳编剧，乔恩·费儒导演。以下是剧情摘要。安迪通过把艾伦和皮特的旧情人以虚假借口召集到办公室，对他们进行报复。托比终于要去面对被定罪的斯克兰顿扼喉手了。他想对他说：“我认为你是无辜的。”帕姆做出了关于她在费城未来的决定，德怀特和安吉拉在照顾雪莉阿姨时有了特别的连结时刻。现在我有一个无比兴奋想要分享的消息。我跟你说，如果你把它铺垫得太高，它就会让人失望。铺垫得太高，它就会让人失望。
Everybody, Angela is doing our top of show today. Yes, because last week we talked all about moving on part one, we did our fast facts. We did. We did some of our call sheet tidbits. So Jenna was like, and you wanna have a go at top of show? And you guys, okay. I think it's gonna be a really fun, fresh energy for you to do Top of Show.
各位，安吉拉今天要主持我们的开场。是的，因为上周我们讨论了“继续前行”第一部分的所有内容，我们做了快速问答。我们确实做了。我们还分享了一些通告单的花絮。所以詹娜就说，你想不想主持开场？你们大家，好吧。我觉得你来主持开场会有一种非常有趣、新鲜的活力。
Well, I have a surprise for you. What is it? I will lead with this. I have two surprises. First of all, did you know that there was a card on the writer's room wall, remember their wall of ideas, that said ski trip? No, I did not. Yes, there was. I did confer with Warren about this. And, you know, Jenna, we've been so fortunate from our writer's assistants to get all of the scripts.
好吧，我有个惊喜要给你。是什么？我先说这个。我有两个惊喜。首先，你知道编剧室的墙上有一张卡片，还记得他们的创意墙吗，上面写着“滑雪之旅”吗？不，我不知道。是的，确实有。我为此跟沃伦确认过。而且，你知道的，詹娜，我们非常幸运，从我们的编剧助理那里拿到了所有的剧本。
I did find a pitch for ski trip. You did not. I did. Apparently, Andy can't stand being inside all day and announces he wants to go on a staff ski trip at the end of the week. Dwight thinks it's a waste of time. Andy says that they have enough discretionary funds for ski lift passes.
我还真找到了一个关于滑雪之旅的提案。你不会吧。我找到了。显然，安迪无法忍受整天待在室内，并宣布他想在周末结束时去参加员工滑雪之旅。德怀特认为这是在浪费时间。安迪说他们有足够的酌情经费来买滑雪缆车票。
There's a deal online and the whole bullpen is very excited about it. And apparently, Angela used to be a competitive skier? Question mark. And then the other thing in the outline said simply this, Kevin in a ski school class. Oh, so Kevin's going to take ski school during this episode? Possibly. There were so many ideas pitched off of this one card that just said ski trip. It just cracked me up thinking about the possibilities if our show ever really traveled anywhere. I think they should not put us all on skis.
网上有个优惠，整个办公区的人都对此感到非常兴奋。显然，安吉拉以前是个竞技滑雪运动员？问号。大纲里的另一项很简单，只有这个：凯文上滑雪学校课程。哦，所以凯文在这集里要去上滑雪学校？有可能。这张只写着“滑雪之旅”的卡片衍生出了这么多的提案。一想到如果我们剧组真的去什么地方旅行，会有哪些可能性，我就觉得好笑。我觉得他们不该让我们所有人都去滑雪。
I mean, how many of us even know how to ski? I didn't know how to ski then. I mean, also look at what happened on work bus. Exactly. Are you gonna put us on a mountain? No way. Anyway, it got me so tickled. And then surprise number two is this ski storyline made me think of how I only journal when I
我是说，我们当中有多少人甚至知道怎么滑雪？我那时候就不会滑雪。我是说，也看看工作巴士那一集发生了什么。确切地说。你要把我们弄到山上去吗？没门。不管怎样，这把我逗乐了。然后第二个惊喜是，这个滑雪的故事让我想起了我只有在旅行时才会写日记。
travel. And guess what? What? I'm going to read you some travel journal entries from my journal from 2004, and it includes a ski trip. Oh my gosh, you need to do top of show more often. I don't know about that. This is what I'm saying. These are delicious, delicious, delicious nuggets.
你猜怎么着？什么？我要读给你听一些我 2004 年旅行日记里的内容，里面就包括一次滑雪之旅。天哪，你得更经常地主持开场。我可不知道。这就是我要说的。这些都是美味至极、妙不可言的干货。
Okay, I'm getting my journal. Look at all my Post-it notes. Look at them where I've marked these entries. Okay, here it goes. I apologize in advance. October 19th, 2004, 410 PM, Tuesday. I love how you put the time. I know.
好吧，我要去拿我的日记本。看看我所有的便利贴。看看我用来标记这些条目的地方。好吧，开始了。我提前道歉。2004年10月19日，下午4点10分，星期二。我喜欢你连时间都记下来。我知道。
This journal entry is from the set of The Office. I'm in the background of a scene. This is our last- By the way, I wanna say, that's not you setting up this journal, that's what you wrote, right? This journal entry. Oh, this journal entry is from the set of The Office. I'm in the background of a scene. This is our last week of work, at least for now. I so underline hope we get picked up. Lord, please let us get picked up. NBC was maybe going
这篇日记是《办公室》片场写的。我在一个场景的背景里。这是我们的最后——顺便说一句，我想说，这不是你在布置这本日记，这是你写的，对吧？这篇日记。哦，这篇日记是《办公室》片场写的。我在一个场景的背景里。这是我们工作的最后一周，至少目前是这样。我无比希望我们能续订。上帝啊，求求你让我们续订吧。NBC 之前可能打算
to pay for an extra episode and we were going to shoot it next week, but they decided not to at the last minute. We're all pretty bummed. I'm sad, but at the same time, I'm happy because I'm going to go see my mom and dad in Texas. Oh, Oscar just drew a Post-It note, and then I added on to it. Here it is." And then you put the Post-It in your journal. I take it in. It's like me if I was a monkey dressed as Angela Martin. And then I added the monkey pooping and then Oscar wrote, Douchet, well played. Was that season one?
为我们支付一集额外费用的制作，我们本打算下周拍摄，但他们最后一分钟取消了。我们都挺沮丧的。我很伤心，但同时我也很高兴，因为我要去德克萨斯看望我爸妈了。哦，奥斯卡刚刚画了一张便利贴，然后我在上面加了点东西。就是这个。”然后你把便利贴贴在了日记里。我把它画了下来。就像是一只打扮成安吉拉·马丁的猴子。然后我画了猴子在大便，接着奥斯卡写道：“绝招，干得漂亮。”那是第一季吗？
2004? Yes. Oh my gosh. Okay. Now is my trip. Okay. Next entry, October 25th, 2004, Monday 1.15 p.m. On American Airlines headed to Dallas, then on to Wichita Falls.
2004年？是的。哦天哪。好了，现在是我的旅行时间。好吧。下一篇日记，2004年10月25日，星期一，下午1点15分。在飞往达拉斯的美国航空飞机上，然后转机去威奇托福尔斯。
It is an international plane. So I have my own TV with 10 channels of stuff to watch, five movie channels, and then ESPN, News Channel, Cartoon Network, and the BBC. Just bought headsets. $2, but worth it. No movies on yet, so I'm listening to classical music. Very soothing. Boeing 777.
这是一架国际航班。所以我拥有自己的电视，有10个频道的节目可以看，5个电影频道，还有ESPN、新闻频道、卡通频道和BBC。刚买了耳机。2美元，但很值。电影还没开始播，所以我正在听古典音乐。非常舒缓。波音777。
What are these details? What is this? Who do I become when I travel? This is so ridiculous. These are, what are these details? What is this? How do I become when I crumble? This is so ridiculous. You start just describing like your literal surroundings. Ridiculous, okay, ready? Yes.
这些都是什么细节？这是什么？我旅行的时候都变成了什么人？太荒谬了。这些是，这些细节是什么？这是什么？我崩溃时怎么会变成这样？这太荒谬了。你开始描述你字面意义上的周围环境。荒谬，好吧，准备好了吗？是的。
Watched Chronicles of Riddick. Little stupid, but okay. I guess for an in-flight movie. So I think I'm gonna miss my connecting flight to Wichita Falls. We'll see, it's gonna be super tight. And then I say, we land at 6 p.m. and my flight leaves at 6.49 p.m.
看了《星际传奇》。有点蠢，不过好吧。我想作为机上电影也行。所以我想我要错过飞往威奇托福尔斯的转机航班了。走着瞧吧，时间会非常紧。然后我说，我们下午6点落地，我的航班是下午6点49分起飞。
I get in at gate A21 and have to go all the way to A2. Huh. Did you write that? Ugh. And then my next entry says, midnight in Archer City, Texas. I'm in the guest room. Unbelievable, I made my connecting flight. And so did my luggage. City, Texas. I'm in the guest room. Unbelievable. I made my connecting flight. And so did my luggage. Amazing, really."
我在A21登机口下机，必须一路走到A2登机口。哈。那是你写的吗？呃。然后我的下一篇日记写道：“德克萨斯州阿彻市的午夜。我在客房里。难以置信，我赶上了转机航班。我的行李也是。德克萨斯州阿彻市。我在客房里。难以置信。我赶上了转机航班。我的行李也是。真的太惊人了。”
Here's what I want everybody out there to know is that that journal entry that you just read could very easily be an audio memo that you left me. Like, those are the details that I get. I get the nitty-gritty. You would, in your audio memo to me, you would probably list out all of the different channels that are available. Then, now I'm in Texas, right? And I wrote, we surprised grandmother with a new stove, and she showed us the 250 foot Sprint cell tower
我想让外面的每个人都知道的是，你刚刚读的那篇日记非常容易变成你留给我的语音备忘录。真的，那就是我收到的那种细节。我得到的是最核心的干货。你在发给我的语音备忘录里，大概会把所有能收看到的频道都列出来。然后，现在我在德克萨斯了，对吧？我写道：“我们给祖母一个惊喜，送了一个新炉子，她给我们看了他们家后面建的250英尺高的斯普朗特手机信号塔。
that they built behind her house. She's oddly and sweetly very proud of it. She took a ton of pictures of it. She took a ton of pictures of it. I'm frightened by it." Oh my God. And now the last one is the ski story. Ready? January 1st, Salt Lake City to San Francisco to LAX. Oh my gosh. Why? Why were you so upset about this? So many connections. So many connections. Very tired. Have a crick in my neck. And I'm so ready for my bed. I miss my home and of course, Lucy and Otter, my cats. The cabin was very cozy. We got in
她对它感到既奇怪又可爱地非常骄傲。她给它拍了超多照片。她给它拍了超多照片。我被它吓到了。”天哪。现在最后一个是滑雪的故事。准备好了吗？1月1日，从盐湖城经旧金山飞往洛杉矶国际机场。哦天哪。为什么？你为什么对这个这么沮丧？转机太多了。转机太多了。非常累。脖子落枕了。我已经准备好回我的床上了。我想念我的家，当然还有我的猫露西和奥特。木屋非常舒适。我们在
at midnight on the 28th and it was snowing and it didn't stop the whole time we were there. It was literally a snowstorm. It even made the national news. Okay. I took a snowboarding class on the worst day of the storm. Typical frowny face. Aw, just your luck. Whomp, whomp. It was a blizzard out there.
28号午夜到达，当时在下雪，而且我们在那里的整个过程中雪都没有停过。简直是一场暴风雪。它甚至上了全国新闻。好吧。我在风暴最糟糕的那一天上了单板滑雪课。典型的苦脸。啊，真是不走运。咚，咚。外面是一场暴风雪。
I quit half an hour. I quit with half an hour left. Everyone else met me in the cafe at 1230 p.m. I was on my second cup of Earl Grey. No regrets. I was miserably cold and you couldn't see three feet down the mountain for the gusts of wind and snow and it just burned through me. I didn't dress warm enough.
我在还剩半小时的时候退出了。我在还剩半小时的时候不学了。大家12点半在咖啡馆汇合。我正在喝我的第二杯伯爵茶。毫不后悔。我冷得要命，狂风暴雪让三英尺外都什么也看不见，这风雪直接刺穿了我。我衣服穿得不够暖。
Ick. Now I'm in the window seat of a three-seat row, flying home. The flight is pretty packed, and the guy in front of me has his seat back, and I seriously feel trapped. Of course, everyone else has put their seat up because we are landing, but not this jack-off in front of me. I wonder why I keep a journal. I mean, I only write in it when we travel. It's almost just a way for me to kill time on a plane, I guess. Oh, I think yes.
哎。现在我坐在三人一排的靠窗座位上，飞回家。航班相当满，我前面的家伙把座椅放倒了，我真的觉得自己被困住了。当然，其他人都把座位调正了，因为我们要降落了，但前面这个混蛋没有。我不知道我为什么还要写日记。我的意思是，我只有在旅行时才会写。我想这几乎只是我在飞机上消磨时间的一种方式。哦，我想是的。
I think yes. Here are things I'd like to do. Semi-colon, write a book or screenplay. Edit my pilot presentation for the show I'm writing about my hometown in Texas. Do another one-woman show. Learn to cook. Learn to speak Spanish more fluently.
我想是的。以下是我想要做的事情。分号，写一本书或剧本。剪辑我为家乡德克萨斯州创作的剧集的试播集展示片。再做一场独角戏。学做饭。学说更流利的西班牙语。
Work on my tennis game. I like that, like, all of a sudden, you turned your journal into, like, a journal. Okay. Like, processing and goal-making. Last entry. Not that your other journal wasn't awesome. The lady next to the guy who won't pull his seat up is now telling him a story about her New Year's Eve in London. Apparently there was a mob scene, very festive and scary. Things I'd like to do continued. Just go straight into it. Get in shape. Seriously
练习网球。我喜欢这种，突然之间，你把日记变成了一本正经的日记。好吧。就像在进行心理梳理和制定目标。最后一篇日记。并不是说你其他的日记不棒。那个不肯把座位调正的家伙旁边的那位女士，现在正在跟他讲她在伦敦过除夕夜的故事。显然当时发生了暴民骚乱，非常热闹也挺吓人。想做的事未完待续。直接切入正题。保持身材。说真的
though, I say that all the time. Oh my God, she's still talking to him about London. Ha ha ha. Oh my God, she's still talking. Gotta run, although writing in this is protecting me from chatty-patty. Wow. There you go. I loved it. And I want to say something. Those things that you wrote down in your journal, almost all of them have manifested now. I mean, I know it's been a long passage of time.
不过，我老是这么说。天哪，她还在跟他聊伦敦的事。哈哈哈哈。天哪，她还在聊。得走了，不过写这个日记保护了我免受唠叨鬼的打扰。哇。就是这样。我太喜欢了。而且我想说点什么。你在日记里写下的那些事情，现在几乎都已经变成了现实。我的意思是，我知道已经过去很长一段时间了。
But I feel like the only one is you never did another one-woman show. No, and that's okay with me. Yeah. Yeah. But wow. I mean, just goes to show you guys, just hang in there for 40 years and the list you make on an airplane. All right. I have no idea if that was interesting to you all,
但我觉得唯一没有实现的，就是你再也没有做过独角戏。不，我对此觉得没关系。对。对。但是哇。我的意思是，这正好向大家证明，只要坚持40年，你在飞机上列的清单就能实现。好吧。我不知道这对你们大家来说是不是很有趣，
but there's my top of show inspired by a card on the writer's room wall. I beyond loved it. Everyone, please vote if you would like Angela to do more top of show. No, no, please don't, please don't. All right, we're going to take a break and we will be back to finish Breaking Down moving on, part two. This episode is going to officially open with Dwight and Angela bathing Aunt Shirley. Quote, bathing in quotes.
但这就是我受编剧室墙上卡片启发而带来的开场。我简直太喜欢了。大家请投票，看看是否希望安吉拉主持更多的开场。不，不，请不要，请不要。好吧，我们要休息一下，回来后继续剖析“继续前行”第二部分。这一集将正式以德怀特和安吉拉给雪莉阿姨洗澡开场。引号，“洗澡”，加了引号。
Yeah, I mean, Dwight shows Angela the bathing area and it's basically Aunt Shirley sitting in a chair and Angela has a giant fire hose and she ends up spraying Dwight with it. We had a fan question from Ludovica F. from Zurich who said, when Angela hoses down Dwight, we see rain reaching down to protect his jewels. Did that hurt him? Can you tell us all about this scene and how many takes it took to do this? Angela? Ludovica, thank you so much for that question because I have lots of stuff to share.
是的，我是说，德怀特向安吉拉展示洗澡区，基本上就是雪莉阿姨坐在椅子上，安吉拉拿着一根巨大的消防水带，最后她用水带把德怀特喷了。我们收到了来自苏黎世的鲁多维卡·F的粉丝提问，她说：“当安吉拉用水龙头冲洗德怀特时，我们看到雨水顺流而下保护他的要害。这弄疼他了吗？你能给我们讲讲这个场景以及拍了多少条吗？安吉拉？”鲁多维卡，非常感谢你的提问，因为我有好多东西想分享。
First of all, we had a hose rehearsal earlier in the week. Yes, Steve Burgess told me you did that, that you did the rehearsal on Monday, you shot this on Thursday. I wasn't clear if you were also at the hose rehearsal. Yes, I was because I had to hold the hose. Okay. So they had these fellas that were showing me
首先，我们在那周早些时候进行了一次水龙头彩排。是的，史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我你们做过这个，你们周一进行了彩排，周四拍摄的。我不确定你是否也参加了水龙头彩排。是的，我参加了，因为我必须拿着水龙头。好吧。所以他们找了几个伙计来教我
how to use it. And I was told that the hose was set to a much lower pressure than it would normally be on because if it was turned all the way on, it would probably lift me off the ground. Oh my gosh. Yeah. They also told me that I really had to try
怎么使用它。并且我被告知，水龙头的压力被调得比正常情况要低得多，因为如果开到最大，它可能会把我整个人冲离地面。哦天哪。是的。他们还告诉我，我真的必须努力
to make sure not to aim at Rain's face Uh-huh because even at a lower setting this water hose to the eyeball could result in a corneal abrasion or an eye contusion Oh my gosh, so you're you aim low aim low aim low. They told me aim low They gave me like a area on Rain's body. It was basically like rib cage to knees to try to aim for. And it was a good thing he wore glasses. They thought that was helpful. I have a question. Was Rain at the rehearsal or just you?
确保不要瞄准雷恩的脸，嗯哼，因为即使在较低的设置下，这个水枪喷到眼球上也可能会导致角膜擦伤或眼部挫伤。哦天哪，所以你瞄准低处，瞄准低处，瞄准低处。他们告诉我瞄准低处。他们给我指出了雷恩身体上的一个大致区域。基本上就是从肋骨到膝盖之间试着瞄准。幸好他戴了眼镜。他们觉得这很有帮助。我有个问题。雷恩当时在彩排现场，还是只有你？
Rain was at the rehearsal too because I had to kind of practice a little bit. Okay. And even at the lower pressure, it was a lot to handle. You sort of see me struggling with it. That's a little bit of acting, but a little bit. And even at the lower pressure, it was a lot to handle. You sort of see me struggling with it. That's a little bit of acting, but a little bit not. Like I didn't have really great aim with it. So I was glad Reign was tall and I had a bigger target. Oh, Creed just tried to call me. I have a missed call from Creed. Oh, Creed has his new album out.
雷恩也在彩排现场，因为我必须稍微练习一下。好吧。而且即使是在较低的水压下，这也很难驾驭。你们大概能看到我在跟它较劲。这有一点点是演技，但也有一点点不是。就像我真的没法用它瞄得很准。所以我很高兴雷恩个子高，我有一个更大的目标。哦，克里德刚才试图给我打电话。我有一个克里德的未接来电。哦，克里德的新专辑发行了。
Oh, yes, he does. Oh my gosh. And he's going on tour. Should I call and ask what he wanted? Sure. Okay. Hello, pumpkin. Hey, Creed-o.
哦，是的，确实发行了。哦天哪。而且他要开始巡演了。我应该打回去问问他想干嘛吗？当然。好吧。喂，南瓜。嘿，克里·O。
I'm here with Jenna. We were doing our podcast when you called. Oh, you're on the show right now. You stopped, I hope. No, no, you're on. You're on. We're excited about your new album. You're hitting the road.
我和詹娜在一起。你打电话来的时候我们正在做播客。哦，你现在就在节目里。你停下了吧，我希望。不，不，你在线。你在线。我们为你新专辑感到兴奋。你要上路巡演了。
You're hitting the road. You're hitting the road. You're hitting the road. You're hitting the road. You're hitting the road. You're on. We're excited about your new album. You're hitting the road, aren't you? I'm going to Europe in October, but the album comes out September 27th. Oh, fine. And the shameless promotion, ladies. Thank you so much. There you go. Well, I miss you. Were you just calling to say hey? Yeah, I was calling to say hey and actually was going to ask you what season you are in. I was just curious.
你要上路巡演了。你要上路巡演了。你要上路巡演了。你要上路巡演了。你要上路巡演了。你在线。我们为你的新专辑感到兴奋。你要上路巡演了，对吧？我十月份要去欧洲，但专辑9月27日发行。哦，很好。女士们，真是不放过任何厚颜无耻的宣传机会啊。非常感谢。就是这样。好吧，我想念你们。你刚才打电话只是为了打个招呼吗？对，我打电话来打个招呼，实际上是想问问你们现在在拍第几季。我只是好奇。
Oh, we're on season nine, Creed. Oh my God, you're getting close to the finale. We are. You'll have to come on. I want everyone to come on for the finale. Me too. I should come on and actually bring my guitar and all the basses. Come on, Creed.
哦，我们在第九季，克里德。天哪，你们快要接近大结局了。是的。你们一定要来客串。我希望每个人都在大结局时来客串。我也是。我应该来客串，甚至带上我的吉他还有所有的贝斯。来吧，克里德。
I would love that. We would love that. I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you.
我会求之不得的。我们会求之不得的。我会想念你的。我会想念你的。我会想念你的。我会想念你的。我会想念你的。我会想念你的。
I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you. I'm going to miss you. I'm going we want to come on for the finale. Me too. I should come on and actually bring my guitar and play all the basses. Come on. Creed, I would love that. We would love it. Not a dry eye in the house. Nope. It was so good to see you on the AT&T thing. That was, it was like, it had been so long.
我会想念你的。我会想念你的。我会想念你的。我会想念你的。我们希望在大结局时来客串。我也是。我应该来客串，甚至带上我的吉他，弹奏所有的贝斯。来吧。克里德，我会求之不得的。我们会求之不得的。全场感动得落泪。不，没有。在AT&T的活动上看到你太棒了。那感觉，就像是已经过了好久。
I know, we got to work together again. It was so amazing. How cute is that? Well, I miss you so much. We need to go for our neighborhood walk. We need to work together again. It was so amazing. How cute is that? Well, I miss you so much. We need to go for our neighborhood walk. We need to do that. Call me later. And now, Creed, tell us when your single comes out.
我知道，我们又能一起工作了。这太棒了。多可爱啊？好吧，我太想你们了。我们需要去我们的社区散步了。我们需要再次一起工作。这太棒了。多可爱啊？好吧，我太想你们了。我们需要去我们的社区散步了。我们得去散步。待会儿给我回电话。现在，克里德，告诉我们你的单曲什么时候发行。
June 24th, corner of the universe. I wrote it with Vance DeGeneres, who used to run Steve's company. That is amazing. Creed, this is crazy. You're calling today. We're recording this episode and it's like perfect timing. Your single is out right now. When this airs. The single will be out when this airs. Yes. Everyone check out Creed's
6月24日，《宇宙的角落》。我和范斯·德杰尼勒斯一起写的，他以前负责史蒂夫的公司。太棒了。克里德，这太疯狂了。你今天打电话来。我们正在录制这集，时间简直完美。你的单曲现在就发行了。等这集播出的时候。这首歌在我这集播出时就会发行了。是的。大家快去听听克里德的
new single. Creed, tell us the name of it again. Corner of the Universe. Corner of the Universe. I can't wait to hear it. We're gonna play a little of it at the end of this episode. And then Creed, we'll put little swipe ups and stuff so folks can find it. And I'm so glad you called, I miss you. That's perfect. Well, my ears were burning. I just got back from having a gluten-free muffin
新单曲。克里德，再告诉我们一次歌名。《宇宙的角落》。《宇宙的角落》。我等不及要听了。我们会在这一集的结尾播放一小段。然后克里德，我们会放一些上滑链接之类的东西，这样粉丝们就能找到了。我很高兴你打电话来，我想念你。太完美了。好吧，我耳朵在发烫。我刚吃完一个无麸质玛芬回来
and all of a sudden I was going, call Angela and Jen. And I don't really, I just picked up the phone and said, well, all right. My voice says call them, I will, and there you go. That's how it works. We love you, Creed. Love you, Creed. I'll see you soon in the neighborhood.
突然我就在想，给安吉拉和詹娜打电话。我其实没想那么多，只是拿起电话说，好吧。我的声音说打给她们，我就打咯，事情就是这样。这就是它的运作方式。我们爱你，克里德。爱你，克里德。回头在社区见。
All right, bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Thank you so much. Yep, bye. That's crazy. That is crazy. That's so, like, that is just serendipity right there.
好的，拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。非常感谢。拜拜。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。这简直，简直就是天意啊。
You know what that is? That's that thing that you talked about that we have as a cast. That like group mind. The group mind. We are connected as we just really are connected. We are. You know, I just am so thankful for it. I feel like I hear from someone in the cast or from you just at that moment when I needed
你知道那是什么吗？那就是你曾说过的我们作为演员群体所拥有的东西。就像集体思维。集体思维。我们是连结在一起的，真的连结在一起。我们是。你知道，我对此非常感激。我觉得每当我需要的时候，总能收到剧组某个人或者你的消息。
it. And I just love that Creed called. I had my ringer off. I wouldn't have seen it, but I had just picked up my phone to play Rain's audio clip and saw that Creed had called. Well, you know, when we did the commercial together, he said he had his new album coming out, and I said, will you call us and let us know when that single drops, because we wanna talk about it
我真的很高兴克里德打来电话。我把铃声关了。我本来看不到的，但我刚好拿起手机准备播放雷恩的音频片段，就看到克里德打来电话。你知道的，当我们一起拍广告时，他说他有新专辑要发行，然后我说，你会打电话告诉我们那首单曲什么时候发布吗，因为我们想在《办公室女郎》里聊聊它？
on Office Ladies? And then he just called like- While we're recording. I just can't get over it. The universe is a beautiful place. Okay, well now where was I? You were about to play the rain audio clip. I was about to play a rain audio clip. So yesterday I texted Rain and I said,
然后他就打电话来了——在我们录制的时候。我简直不敢相信。宇宙真是个美丽的地方。好吧，现在我讲到哪儿了？你正准备播放雷恩的音频片段。我正准备播放雷恩的音频片段。所以昨天我给雷恩发短信说：
Hey tall fella, random question for you. Did it hurt you when I sprayed you with that fire hose and moving on? A few people noted I hit your crotch. I mean, it was a fire hose. I'm so sorry. And then I filmed the scene and I sent him the scene and I told him, I said, I did remember they told me
“嘿，大个子，问你个随机的问题。在《继续前行》里我用水枪喷你的时候，弄疼你了吗？有些人注意到我击中了你的下半身。我的意思是，那可是消防水带。非常抱歉。”然后我截取了那个场景发给他，并告诉他，我说，我确实记得他们告诉我
not to spray your face. And here is Rain's response. Hey, Angela, thank you for sending that. Oh my God. That is one of the scenes I had completely forgotten that we had shot. And I forgot that that had existed. And I was just laughing so hard watching it
不要喷你的脸。以下是雷恩的回复：“嘿，安吉拉，谢谢你发给我这个。天哪。这是我完全忘掉我们拍过的场景之一。我甚至忘了它的存在。我看着它笑得肚子疼，
because now I remember filming it. It didn't hurt at all. I don't know, maybe that giant plastic apron I had on, it didn't hurt my crotch or anything, but I imagine if you had blasted me in the face, that's what she said, that it would have hurt a great deal. But I remember that being very super fun and funny now and thank you for the little reminder but I have no other memories other than it was fun and we were near the end of our show crazy. All right well there you have it it did not hurt him I did by accident get the side of his ear one time I do remember that and I remember him after the next take saying,
因为现在我想起拍摄时的情景了。一点也不疼。我不知道，也许是因为我身上穿着那个巨大的塑料围裙，它并没有弄疼我的下半身或别的什么，但我想如果你把水直接喷在我脸上——这话听着真污——那肯定会非常疼。不过我现在觉得那段拍摄超级有趣、好笑，谢谢你的小提醒，除了觉得好笑而且当时我们已经快拍完剧了之外，我没有别的记忆了，太疯狂了。”好吧，大家听到了吧，并没有弄疼他。我确实不小心喷到了他耳朵边一次，我记得这个。我还记得他在拍完下一条后说：
don't get my ear. And I was like, I didn't mean to get your ear. But the other thing I wanna tell you is that several crew members came up to me and said that was the best part of their day. Was watching you hose rain. Yes. Well, Steve Burgess said that he doesn't remember
“别喷我耳朵。”我说过我不是故意喷你耳朵的。不过我想告诉你们的另一件事是，好几位剧组成员走过来对我说，那是他们一天中最开心的一部分。就是看你用水枪冲雷恩。是的。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他不记得
how many takes you had to do, but it was more than one. Oh, it was. Yeah. He also said that all of Aunt Shirley's house for this episode was at the Warner Brothers Ranch, which you shared last week. But he said this barn where you did the hosing was the barn from the Waltons. Yes. The Warner Brothers ranch is huge. So where we filmed the house, which was near the Friends Fountain, we talked about that last week, was a totally different part of this ranch.
你们拍了多少条，但绝对不止一条。哦，确实不止。是的。他还说，这一集里雪莉阿姨的家全都是在华纳兄弟牧场拍的，你们上周也分享过这个。但他说你们喷水那个谷仓是《沃尔顿家族》里的那个谷仓。是的。华纳兄弟牧场非常大。所以我们拍房子的那个地方，就在老友记喷泉附近，我们上周聊过，那是牧场里一个完全不同的部分。
The barn is like kind of back where they had more of the old west stuff. Okay. I do want you guys to know, of course, Rain told me to go for it, because I was like, I don't know, I'm scared. He was like, just hose me. I was like, okay. And this scene was longer in the shooting draft and we did shoot it.
谷仓大概在他们有更多老西部布景的靠后区域。好吧，我想让大家知道，当然雷恩叫我放手去喷，因为我当时说，我不知道，我好害怕。他说：“直接喷我吧。”我说：“好吧。”这个场景在拍摄剧本里更长，而且我们确实拍了。
It had one extra beat. After I yell at them and say, do you have a bathtub? And Dwight's like, yes. And then I'm like, good. It would have continued one more beat. In the shooting draft, it read like this. Angela drops the hose and marches inside. Aunt Shirley says to Dwight, feisty one. And Dwight titillated says, yes, she is. Well, that leads me into this fan question from Joanne M. from Calgary, Alberta, Canada, who said, I love the side of Angela that we get to see in these episodes. She might be intolerant and bitchy, but she is a strong woman. She does not put up with crap. And I want to know how Angela
它多了一个拍点。在我对他们大喊并说“你们有浴缸吗？”之后，德怀特说“有”。然后我说“很好”。它会再延伸一个拍点。在拍摄剧本里，它是这样写的：安吉拉放下水管，气势汹汹地走进屋内。雪莉阿姨对德怀特说：“真有脾气。”德怀特带着一丝情欲说：“是的，她确实是。”好吧，这就引出了来自阿尔伯塔省卡尔加里的乔安妮·M的粉丝提问，她说：“我喜欢在这几集里展现出来的安吉拉的另一面。她可能有些不宽容、刻薄，但她是个坚强的女性。她不容忍任何废话。我想知道安吉拉
felt about this new side of her character being highlighted. She's awesome in this one. Oh, Joanne, thank you. I just had so much fun. You know, we'd all been playing these characters for a long time, and whenever we got to show a new side of them, our new layer, it was like the first day all over again, that kind of excitement. So I was so tickled. I don't know. I liked her so much in this.
对于她角色的这一新面貌被突显出来有什么感受？她在这一集里太棒了。”哦，乔安妮，谢谢你。我真的觉得太有趣了。你知道的，我们扮演这些角色很长时间了，每当有机会展现他们的新一面或新层次时，那种兴奋感就像是第一天拍戏一样。所以我感到非常高兴。不管怎样，我太喜欢她在这一集里的表现了。
Yeah, I did too. I did too. So next up, Toby's at the water cooler and he is still talking to Nellie rehashing details of this Grant and Strangler case. Yeah, he's kind of trying to flirt with her. And if I had a Dundee for Toby, it would be called Worst Pickup Line. I know. Goes to Toby Flinderson. You have to hear this. Hey, Nellie. I am so sick of February. It's the shortest month, but it sure doesn't feel that way. We should catch up. Wow. Why? He takes a sip of water and then goes, mmm. Like really?
是的，我也很喜欢。我也很喜欢。所以接下来，托比在饮水机旁，他还在跟内莉喋喋不休地唠叨斯克兰顿扼喉手案的细节。是的，他有点在试图调情。如果我给托比颁发一个邓迪奖，它应该叫“最烂搭讪奖”。我知道。颁给托比·弗林德森。你们得听听这个。“嘿，内莉。我真是厌倦二月了。它是最短的月份，但感觉可一点也不短。我们应该叙叙旧。”哇。为什么？他喝了一口水，然后说：“嗯——”就像，真的吗？
What is happening? Oh, man. February, huh? Like what? Well, this storyline of Toby still investigating the Scranton Strangler case was originally shot for couples discount. We had cut this whole Toby runner from couples discount and we had to put it in this episode
这是怎么回事？哦，天哪。二月，哈？就像什么？好吧，托比还在调查斯克兰顿扼喉手案这条故事线，原本是为“情侣折扣”那一集拍摄的。我们把整段托比的支线从“情侣折扣”里剪掉了，然后不得不把它塞进这一集里
to help make it an hour long. And Dave Rogers told us that this fit perfectly. There was one thing that we had to shoot. We had to do a little pickup because Toby originally started this conversation with Nellie by asking if she wanted to go to the nail salon with him. But obviously that wouldn't work here. So they shot your fancy pickup line instead, Angela. And Dave said, you can tell if you look really closely, you can see that in the reshoot footage,
来凑够一个小时的时长。戴夫·罗杰斯告诉我们，这段剪进来简直天衣无缝。只有一个镜头是我们需要补拍的。我们必须做个小补拍，因为托比原本是通过问内莉想不想跟他一起去美甲沙龙来开启这段对话的。但显然在这里行不通。所以他们改拍了你那个花哨的搭讪台词，安吉拉。戴夫说，如果你仔细看的话，你会发现在重拍的镜头里，
Toby's hair is a little shorter because he had gotten a haircut between these two episodes. And when I looked at it, I think it switched to the old footage at three minutes and four seconds. You can tell just by his hair, otherwise it is completely seamless. And by the way, I wouldn't even have thought anything if Dave hadn't told me. Pete is now going to go into Andy's office
托比的头发稍微短了一点，因为他在拍这两集之间理发了。当我仔细看时，我觉得在第3分04秒时切换回了旧素材。单凭他的头发就能看出来，除此之外完全天衣无缝。顺便说一句，如果戴夫没告诉我，我甚至根本不会注意到。皮特现在要走进安迪的办公室
to try to encourage him to move on. Pete, Pete, Pete, Pete, what are you thinking? What are you thinking? What are you thinking? He's like, hey, you got a sec to talk. And Andy says, kind of painful to chat with you, Pete, ever since the old one-two punch to my scrotum pole translation penis translation my manhood. This is the moment I'm like, Pete, if someone says that to you, just do a 180 and walk out. Bail. If they bring up their, just do a 180 and walk out. Bail.
来鼓励他往前看。皮特，皮特，皮特，皮特，你在想什么？你在想什么？你在想什么？他说：“嘿，有空聊聊吗？”安吉拉说：“跟你聊天挺痛苦的，皮特，自从你给我来了一记经典的组合拳打在我的阴囊——翻译一下，阴茎——翻译一下，我的男子气概上。”这就是我忍不住想说：皮特，如果有人对你这么说，立刻掉头就走。跑路。如果他们提起他们的，立刻掉头就走。跑路。
If they bring up their scrotum pole, I'm out. Yeah. Well, instead, Pete's going to double down and he's going to try to share a story about his own past breakup with his ex-girlfriend Alice. And he's going to say, listen, it was hard at first, but now we're Facebook friends. And I think maybe we could all be friends, you know, if you could, you know, kind of get over it. Just get over it. And Aaron comes in and it's like, listen, he's trying to tell you something here. Yeah.
如果他们提起他们的阴囊，我就撤了。是的。好吧，相反，皮特非但没有离开，反而加倍下注，试图分享一个关于他自己跟前女友爱丽丝分手的过去故事。他说：“听着，一开始很难，但现在我们是Facebook好友了。而且我想也许我们都可以做朋友，你知道的，如果你能，你知道的，稍微放下过去的话。”就放下过去吧。然后艾伦进来了，说：“听着，他在这里是想跟你说点什么。”是的。
Oh, Andy is not having it. He has a talking head where he says, if life gives you lemons, you just got to eat them, rinds and all. And if you don't want to eat them, your ex-girlfriend will shove them down your throat with the help of her hunky new boyfriend. And we got a fan question, aka a hot take. Is this from Jenna in Los Angeles? It's not. It's from Rihanna B. And we got a lot of mail like this for this episode. So I thought we should discuss. Rihanna said, did you both find this really frustrating to watch?
哦，安吉拉——哦不，安迪根本不吃这一套。他有一个单人访谈，在里面他说：“如果生活给你柠檬，你只能连皮带肉把它吃下去。如果你不想吃，你的前女友就会在她那个身材健硕的新男友的帮助下，把它硬塞进你的喉咙里。”我们收到一个粉丝提问，也就是一个犀利观点。这是来自洛杉矶的詹娜吗？不是。这是来自里安娜·B的。我们为这一集收到了很多这样的邮件。所以我觉得我们应该讨论一下。里安娜说：“你们两个不觉得这一集看得很让人沮丧吗？
Andy is so unhinged in these episodes. The fact that he was a terrible partner to Erin and it was his own behavior that resulted in the breakup. But then he goes and takes it out on her and Pete. Unfortunately, as women were often made to feel responsible for our ex-partner's behaviors and I found it harder to watch than Scott's Tots." Wow. Mm-hmm. That's a real level of cringe if it's harder than Scott's Tots. I know.
安吉拉——哦不，安迪在这几集里太精神失常了。事实上，他对艾伦是个糟糕的伴侣，正是他自己的行为导致了分手。但随后他却把气撒在她和皮特身上。不幸的是，作为女性，我们常常被迫为前任伴侣的行为承担责任，我觉得这一集比《斯科特的 Tots》还要难以下咽。”哇。嗯哼。如果比《斯科特的 Tots》还难看，那真是达到了一定程度的尴尬了。我知道。
So, Rihanna, I thought about this. I think I was so delighted by Ed Helms' performance in this episode that I sort of enjoyed his unraveling. Yeah, you know, I mean, I get what she's saying for sure. But I think for me, starting with moving on, part one, when Andy's trying to figure out and it's just plain as day and he doesn't know that plop is Pete, and then all of those scenes and how it builds,
所以，里安娜，我思考过这个问题。我想我太喜欢埃德·赫尔姆斯在这集里的表演了，以至于我有点享受他情绪崩溃的过程。是的，你知道的，我当然明白她的意思。但我觉得对我来说，从“继续前行”第一部分开始，当安迪试图弄清楚状况而真相明明昭然若揭、他却不知道小胖就是皮特时，所有那些场景以及它是如何层层推进的，
I just was so tickled. Same. And I do hear what she's saying, which I think is actually what we're calling out in this episode, which is that here's Andy, whose behavior resulted in this breakup, but now we're taking care of Andy, right? We're having to deal with his spin-out
我都觉得太逗了。我也是。而且我确实理解她所说的，这其实也正是我们在这一集里所指出的，那就是安吉拉——哦不，安迪，他的行为导致了这次分手，但现在我们却得照顾安吉拉——哦不，照顾安迪，对吧？我们不得不处理他的情绪崩溃，
because he's not able to sort of reflect and take responsibility for what got him there, which makes him a frustrating person. Yeah, but it's easier to spin out about other people's s*** than really address your own. Always. Always. Well now we go back to Philly because Pam's tour of the real estate office is continuing. Mark is showing her the front desk where she'll be sitting. Yes, and Pam is like, what is it? Like, it's clearly a receptionist desk and she thought the job was office manager. Yeah. And he says, yeah, you'd manage the office, maybe answer the phones, forward some
因为他无法进行反思并为导致他落到这田地的原因承担责任，这让他成了一个令人沮丧的人。是的，但是把别人的狗屁事情拿来发疯，总比真正去面对你自己的要容易。永远如此。永远如此。现在我们回到费城，因为帕姆对房地产办公室的参观还在继续。马克正在带她看她以后要坐的前台。是的，帕姆心想：这是什么？这显然是个接待员的办公桌，而她以为这份工作是办公室经理。是的。他说：“对，你要管理办公室，可能接听电话，转接一些
calls, maybe go get coffee for people now and again. And Pam's like, so kind of like a receptionist. Yeah. And he's like, yeah, but we call you the office manager because it's less demeaning. He just like, great. Calls it out. Then he's like, by the way, how long are these cameras going to be around following you?
电话，偶尔可能帮大家买买咖啡。”帕姆就想：“所以有点像个接待员咯。”是的。他说：“对，但我们管你叫办公室经理，因为这听起来不那么贬低人。”他就像是，太棒了。直接点破。然后他说：“顺便说一句，这些摄像机打算跟着你拍多久？
Because I think it's pretty cool. Pretty, pretty cool. So the pretty, pretty cool was an improv. When he brings up Larry David's show, Curb Your Enthusiasm, Do You Like That Show, all of that was an improv. When he brings up Larry David's show, Curb Your Enthusiasm, Do You Like That Show, all of that was improvised. The scene would have stopped at just one Pretty Cool. Interesting.
因为我觉得这挺酷的。非常，非常酷。”那个“非常，非常酷”是即兴发挥的。当他提起拉里·戴维的节目《抑制热情》、问你喜欢那个节目吗时，所有这些全都是即兴发挥的。当他提起拉里·戴维的节目《抑制热情》、问你喜欢那个节目吗时，所有这些全都是即兴发挥的。这个场景本该在说了一句“挺酷的”之后就结束。有趣。
Well, Pam's gonna have a talking head and she just says she was Michael's receptionist for 10 years and she has kids now and she can't do it. She's out. She's out. She's out. There are a few things left over from this real estate office I want to share. Okay.
好吧，帕姆有一个单人访谈，她说她当了迈克尔10年的接待员，她现在有孩子了，她做不了这个。她不干了。她不干了。她不干了。这个房地产办公室还有一些遗留的东西我想分享。好吧。
One is, did you notice the phone number listed on Pam's resume? No. Should we call it? Is it real? I don't know. It's not a 555? No.
一个是，你注意到帕姆简历上列出的电话号码了吗？没有。我们要打打看吗？是真的吗？我不知道。不是555开头的吧？不是。
All right, dial it. Don't say what it is, but dial it. I'm not gonna say what it is. Oh my gosh, what if someone answers? Oh my gosh. It is 555, I can see it. It is not. Yes, it's an area code and then 555.
好吧，拨号。别说是什么号码，但拨一下。我不会说的。哦天哪，如果有人接听怎么办？哦天哪。是555开头的，我看到了。才不是。是的，是一个区号，然后是555。
No one has 555. I thought the 555 was the area code. No, it's the first three numbers. So nothing will happen? Well, no, it's not real. You're doing it anyway. You don't believe me. Okay, your call cannot be completed at this time. Please try again later. Yeah, it'll never be completed. By any time. Who knew? I didn't know that you didn't know that if you see a 555. It's
没人用555。我以为555是区号。不，那是前三位数字。所以什么都不会发生？好吧，不，这不是个真号码。你还是拨了。你不相信我。好吧，你的来电无法接通。请稍后再拨。对，永远也接不通。任何时候都不行。谁知道呢？我不知道你居然不知道如果看到555。它
not a real number. No, that is for all of time for decided this? In movies and television, you do a 555. And then here's the thing. I don't know if you've ever noticed this. In movies, sometimes, instead of saying 555 because people have become wise, other people have become wise to the fact. Not me, but everyone else knows for all of time, 555 is a baloney number. That's right. So what they'll do if you see it written down in some movies, like I'm throwing this out there, I don't know if it's true, but all the president's men, they'll get a hot tip,
不是一个真号码。不，这在电影和电视里是永久性的潜规则。在电影和电视里，你会用555。然后是这样的。我不知道你有没有注意到这一点。在电影里，有时候，由于人们已经变聪明了，其他人已经看穿了这一点。不是我，但其他人一直以来都知道，555是个假号码。没错。所以如果有些电影里把它写下来——我随口举个例子，我不知道是不是真的，比如《总统班底》，他们会得到一个重磅线索、
a phone number they have to call, and it'll say JL5 and then the rest of the phone number because J and L are fives. You know how sometimes people replace where you know, where it's like 1-800-HELP. You know, like how businesses have numbers like 1-800- 1-800-blah blah blah. Call help or something. I don't know. That's more numbers than you need. But you got it. So yeah, they'll be like JL5 blah blah blah blah blah blah blah. That's a way to try to disguise it.
一个他们必须拨打的电话号码，上面会写着JL5然后是电话号码的其余部分，因为J和L都代表5。你知道有时候人们怎么替代吗，你知道的，就像“1-800-HELP”。你知道，就像有些企业号码是“1-800- 1-800-blah blah blah”。拨打求助什么的。我不知道。这比你需要的数字要多。但你懂的。所以，对，他们会写JL5啦啦啦啦啦。这是试图掩人耳目的一种方式。
Well, okay. My other thing about the real estate office is we have talked about the fact that Greg Daniels loved the episode that Jon Favreau turned in so much. He didn't want to cut anything. And we had to even add stuff. That's right. There were two talking heads, one by Mark, played by Bob, and then one by Michael Weston,
好吧，关于房地产办公室，我还有一点要说，我们之前聊过格雷格·丹尼尔斯非常喜欢乔恩·费儒交上来的那一集，以至于他什么都不想剪。我们甚至还得添加内容。没错。有两个单人访谈，一个是马克（由鲍勃饰演），另一个是由迈克尔·韦斯顿饰演的、
who played sort of the Jim-esque character and they are on the deleted scenes and I thought you might want to hear them. Let's listen. Yeah I'm in real estate yeah I mean you ever see the movie Glenn Gary Glenn Ross? Well I'm Ross. I've never seen that movie but and that's not how we do business I know the general gist we're on the up and up but it is exciting. I mean, I don't know what you guys have been doing following this lady around, but this is the real estate game.
有点像吉姆那样角色的访谈，这些都在删减片段里，我想你们可能会想听听。我们听听看。好吧，我是做房地产的，对，我的意思是，你看过电影《拜金一族》吗？好吧，我就是那个罗斯。我从没看过那部电影，但，这不是我们做生意的方式，我知道大致意思，我们行得正坐得端，但这确实很刺激。我的意思是，我不知道你们这些家伙一直跟着这位女士在搞什么鬼，但这就是房地产游戏。
Look at that. Look at that. Feel that energy. They're coiled springs. Following this lady around. Also when he goes, look at that, it's just everyone ignoring him, just doing like their mundane tasks. And then here's the talking head by the Jim S character. My best friends in this office are Cut the Rope, Angry Birds, Mindweeper, still playing Minesweeper. But as far as human contact around here,
看看那个。看看那个。感受一下那种能量。他们就像紧绷的弹簧。跟着这位女士到处跑。还有当他说“看看那个”时，根本没人理他，大家都在做着各自世俗琐碎的任务。然后是那个“吉姆式”角色的单人访谈。我在这个办公室里最好的朋友是：切绳子、愤怒的小鸟、扫雷，我还在玩扫雷。但至于这里的真人接触，
nah, I do my best to avoid it. I love both of those. I know, right? Oh my goodness. I get cutting them because if we give those characters talking heads, it's like we're starting to get, I think, a little too down the rabbit hole with that business.
不，我尽最大努力避开它。我两个都好喜欢。我知道，对吧？哦天哪。我理解把它们剪掉的原因，因为如果我们给那些角色安排单人访谈，就感觉我们对那条商业支线挖掘得有点太深了。
Yeah, I just don't think it needed it. No. Yeah. Well, Pam is going to leave this real estate office forever now. But before we leave this real estate office, Angela and I need to give a shout out to Kristen S. from Philly. Yes, we do. Talk about a heck of a background catch.
In this office, there is a big whiteboard. Yep. And it has a bunch of writing on it. Angela, I know you paused on it. I did. Of course. And then I saw what Kristen wrote in and I thought, oh my gosh, she covered it all. She sure did. Here's what's on that whiteboard. It's a bunch of street names, basically addresses. You know, this is a real estate office. Here's what Kristin had to say. While there are a handful of streets
that don't track with real addresses, like Jonesburg Place and Reinhardt Lane, many of the streets are real. They are well-known center city streets like Delancey, Pine Street, South Street, Locust, Girard Avenue, and even Penn Square, as well as smaller streets like Woodbine and Gravers Lane.
But what's really brilliant is that in many cases, the unit numbers track with the property type. And then she says, for example, commercial real estate in Center City has unit numbers that match for a tall office building that would be in that location. 1420 Market Street isn't a real address, but it would be in the heart of downtown and would likely have a 20th floor unit, as noted. While others in more apartment-dense neighborhoods track like apartment units like 1842 Pine Street No. 10, and areas that are dense with single-family homes like 8412 Gerrard
track just as well. What I think is brilliant about this is that none of these are real addresses you could find by walking. For example, so while there is a Penn Square, there isn't a 1224 South Penn Square. But kudos to the team for inventing realistic places that also aren't real. That's pretty amazing. I mean, I love that attention to detail. They could have just scribbled anything up there, but the time that they took to make that track for real is just kudos to our set deck.
I'm always impressed by all the amounts of detail, even in Aunt Shirley's home. I was of detail, even in Aunt Shirley's home. I was going to break down everything in Aunt Shirley's home, but there's so much clutter. But Kristen, I loved your background catch of everything on the whiteboard. That was fantastic. And you know what? If there was a whiteboard that was supposedly representing my hometown of St. Louis, I'd be curious.
It would be like glaringly obvious to me if it was all fakey. And so I love that someone from Philly was like, yes. Yeah. Up next, Dwight is gonna walk in on Angela braiding Aunt Shirley's hair. Yes, I love her snarky remark that a woman of her age shouldn't have hair this long.
That was an improv by me. What? Yes. No, Angela, it's so funny. It's true, it's an improv by me. The scene would have ended with Angela Martin saying, "'Loose braids reflect a loose character, now stay still.' And Shirley would have said, yes ma'am.
That's the end of the scene. Okay. And then I improvised, "'I think your hair is much too long for your age, by the way.' And Shirley says, okay. And I say, there is much too long for your age, by the way. And Shirley says, okay. And I say there. And she goes, thank you, Angela.
I love that bit of improv. That's so good. All right. So now Toby is going to enter the kitchen. Nellie and Daryl are sitting reading their newspapers and Toby's going to announce he's going to the prison to visit the Scranton Strangler. I had a fan catch. Okay.
That was also seen by Judy in Westerville, Ohio and Catherine S in Nolensville, Tennessee. If you watch the shots of Nellie, her newspaper is like always in a different position. Oh no. Every shot. They so clearly use different takes because like in one she has it totally open and then another it's folded in half. In one she's reading the
comics and then in another she's reading an article and I have to say I feel like maybe she was really reading the newspaper. Because she was turning pages. Yes, like between takes. Pam has now left the real estate office. She's back at Jim's apartment in Philly, and he calls to ask her how the interview went. But before she can really get into it, he's like, you know what, tell me everything about it at 8 o'clock dinner.
He's going to have dinner for her. And she's like, OK. Yeah, he says dinner at 8. Pam's a little bit like, oh, 8. OK, yeah, I guess I can kill four hours. It's Philly after all. I'll find something to do. But this scene was important because it's very clear to Pam, oh, at this job, Jim's gonna work till eight.
I also thought too, as a mother of young children, actually still, even though I have teenagers, we eat at like 5.30. Of course. So eight o'clock, if I get invited to a dinner party and they're like, food's gonna be served at eight, o'clock, if I get invited to a dinner party and they're like, food's gonna be served at eight, I'm like, Josh, we're packing snacks.
I don't go to dinners that start at eight. Well, I mean, we don't really either. You know, if I did, I would pack snacks. Yeah, if I text someone about dinner, I put it out there right away. I say, hey, would you be up for an early dinner on Tuesday, like 5.30, six o'clock? Mm-hmm, although that's not early for you, that's just when you eat.
That's just my dinner time. I know. Yeah. But I don't want to just say, do you want to go to dinner? Because I don't want them to text me back and say, how's 730? Because I'm not going to like it. No. But here's the thing. This is planting the seed for Pam, for where we're going to get in the next episode. She's realizing that this new life in Philly includes a husband who works at the office until eight and is probably missing their kids, bath, dinner, bedtime, all of it. And I also want to say, while it's going to be romantic that she's eating at Athlead, he should have taken her out to a nice restaurant in Philly, don't you think? I don't know, it's like they don't even get to go out. They're gonna eat at his job?
Am I wrong? I know it's sweet, but I don't know. Yeah, I can see that. Right? Yeah. I don't know. Her whole life is his job is what I'm getting at. They even have to have dinner at his job.
Yeah, no, I see that. I see that. How often does she get to Philly? They can't go to a restaurant. That's what I'm saying. I think we didn't want to pay for a restaurant set, but I also think it's going to be important because when they have this conversation, it's like literally this business is breathing down her neck. It's all around her. It's consuming their whole lives. It's very cinematic in that way. It's great from a story point of view. And also, I think they're
able to talk about things that they wouldn't at a restaurant. It's great from a story point of view. And also, I think they're able to talk about things that they wouldn't at a restaurant. The conversation goes to a place that's very real. Yeah. And you usually don't let that happen in a public place. That's what I call the car ride home. Yeah, it all comes out. That's right. Well, listen, I think we should take a break because some crazy shiitake is going to go down a Dunder Mifflin. Yes. Andy is bringing back Aaron and Pete's exes to see how they just move on and get over things. That's right.
How's that medicine taste? Your own flavored? Yeah. We'll be back. We are back and there is a new employee that arrives from BCI Consultants. Her name is Alice and she says she's here to meet with Andy. Erin starts to show her through the bullpen. Meredith yells fresh meat and makes kissing noises. Way to go, Meredith. And then as Aaron and
Alice walk by Kevin, who's at the water cooler, he says, I'm Kevin. And they just keep walking right past him. They do. That was an improv line by Brian Baumgartner. Amazing, Brian. Well, let me tell you, Alice was played by Colette Wolf. And there's a very big crossover connection here because Colette had been in Hot Tub Time Machine with Craig Robinson and Clark Duke. She went on to appear in Hot Tub Time Machine 2. You might recognize her from her recurring role
on Cougar Town. She was most recently on Quantum Leap, and she had a starring role in the movie The Foot-Fist Way with Danny McBride. Do you remember when that came out? No. Oh my gosh. It was like, when I was looking up her credits
and I saw that, I was like, oh, I remember that movie. It just, it launched Danny McBride's career. It's very office-like in its tone and style, and he's a Taekwondo instructor. Oh, I kind of remember this now, yes, he like goes on a pilgrimage to find his hero. And it's very, very funny, and she starred in that. Well, she was also in Interstellar,
which is such a good movie. Yes. She's just been in everything, though. If you look at her resume, she's done so much work. Well, when Erin gets to the annex, Alice immediately recognizes Pete. Pete's like, oh no. And she goes, is this random? And he's like, no. Pete knows right away what's up. And then Aaron realizes Andy also hired a management consultant. She's like, oh no. She runs to reception. And sure enough, there's Gabe. Creed
says, Hey, Aaron, look, who's back the birdman? Gabe says, Hello, beautiful. Kevin says, Didn't you two used to do it? And Gabe said, We absolutely did. Thank you for remembering that. Yeah. And he's watching from his office. He is delighted. Well, now Toby is going to arrive to the prison. Guess what? It wasn't a prison. I wouldn't think so. Well they actually scouted several prisons. Really? Yes, and they didn't like any of them.
Okay. They got some actual exterior photos of Pitches Detention Center in California, and then they used those photos to make their own prison. The actual location was Van Nuys High School. Oh. Yeah, so that's where they shot this. And you notice we never went inside. Right. Mm-hmm. It stays all exterior. Toby's talking head is so ridiculous. I mean, what does he think is going to happen? Well, he says he thinks it's going to be the start of my first friendship. I know.
He's going to meet George Howard Scubb and tell him he believes he is innocent. Yeah. And he would understand if George feels moved to hug him. Well, he feels moved to do something. We'll get there. Back in the annex, Clark is sort of loving this awkward moment between Pete and Alice. Andy enters and it becomes very clear that he is also reveling in this awkward tension that he's created. And this is when Alice is going to realize there is no marketing department. Yeah. I just want to say, shouldn't Dunder Mifflin have a marketing department? Like, we have three accountants but no marketing department? We have three accountants and what does Creed do?
I don't know. There surely should be a marketing department. Well, there isn't one, but there are some lines in this that I just loved from Andy. When Pete is saying like, this is really awkward Andy, like, and then he says, oh, is it professor lecture much and he says how's that
medicine taste your own flavored is it just me or have these tables turned he's got so many there was another one in the script where instead of saying is it just me have these tables turned at the end of the scene he would have have said, turned, table for one. Well, back at reception, Gabe is telling Erin how he's been coping since their breakup. He says, you know, times were tough. I was unemployed. I was still heartbroken over you. I lost a good 50 pounds. But as you can see, I put all that weight right back on. Fill how fat my buttocks are. And then Zach Woods improvised this. Yeah, it's crazy.
Touch it. It's like a warm pumpkin. Mm-hmm. Yeah, because of our interview with Jake, where he said that Zach improvised so much, I did the same thing. I went to the script while I was watching the episode and I saw like a warm pumpkin.
How about in the conference room? So much. So many lines improvised in the conference room. And probably more takes that didn't even make it into the episode. Mm-hmm. We cut back to the prison and this must have been the shortest visit ever because Toby is now being wheeled out on a stretcher. He's clasping his neck. Yeah, then we cut to a car ride home. Nellie has picked Toby up and he's wearing a, cut to a car ride home, Nellie has picked Toby up and he's wearing a, what do you call it?
A neck brace. He can't speak because his vocal cords have been damaged when George Scubb strangled him at the end of their visit. I have to say something. What is it? I got so tickled at Paul's neck acting. Yes. Because it is very broad.
Okay. When she's like nod yes or no, he's like, he's like moving his whole body. Yes, it's true. It was very funny to me. Well, we got this fan question from Robert S. in Colorado Springs, California, and it says fan theory.
I believe the scene after the prison visit further proves Toby was the strangler all along. How so? Here's what Robin said. I think Toby was trying to prove George Howard Scubb innocent solely out of his own guilt because he never fully explains why he is so sure Scubb is innocent.
Toby went to the prison and off camera told Scubb the truth, that he knew all along that he was innocent, and I'm sure he had to admit to Scubb why he was so sure because it was him. And then, out of anger, George Scubb retaliated. Because if the prison or the prison guards truly thought George Scubb was capable of harming someone, they would have taken more precautions with visitations, if anything, just to avoid a lawsuit. Scubb was likely a model prisoner behind bars, therefore the prison had no concerns about him becoming violent. But after hearing that someone on the jury who was actually the strangler got him falsely imprisoned, he acted accordingly. Why else would he attack someone trying to prove his innocence? So I think with this theory, you're basically saying Toby's a sociopath.
Yes. That Toby went in there and whispered in his ear, because it's true, they did not allow the cameras in the prison. So he whispered something really diabolical like, I know you're innocent because I did it. That same guy is the same guy who took a sip of water and went, I am so tired of February. That's diabolical. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. Well, Robin, thank you for writing that in because I love a good fan theory. I do too. There is debate about Toby.
People are determined for him to be the Scrantz Strangler. I know. We are back at dinner now at Aunt Shirley's house. Angela is serving a dinner stew with a roasted skunk. Dwight offers her the stink sack, which is I guess like a wishing bone. And Aunt Shirley's like, when's the wedding? And this snaps Angela out of it. Yeah.
She's like, oh, no, no, no, we're just friends. We got so much fan mail about this scene, Angela. Is it about the skunk? Yes. It's about your character being a vegetarian. And yet you have prepared a meal, a stew, that includes skunk. And talk about fan theories. Some people said maybe the skunk was like roadkill, and so you had no problem preparing something that had died by accident. That was one of the theories. But in general, you know, we don't see you eating it. Mm-hmm, but People were curious that you had prepared a meal that included me as a non meat eater
I actually have two friends who are vegetarians But their husbands and children are not mm-hmm two separate families and both of these women when they prepare food prepare Meat for their families, even though they themselves are vegetarians. Okay, so they prepare food, prepare meat for their families, even though they themselves are vegetarians. So that isn't a huge jump for me, that she helped make this meal, probably with Dwight, alongside Dwight or Shirley. There is no food on Angela's plate,
and there are roasted vegetables. And I could see her kind of being in this moment of like family and togetherness. You know, she's not gonna go sit at another table and be like, ew. But I also think she loves Dwight. And maybe if Kevin had prepared skunk, she would have been bitchy to him. But this is Dwight. She's in the moment. You know, I think some people were confused by the stink sack. I think they thought he was offering it to you to eat it. But when he says it's like the wishbone,
I felt like there's some other thing you're gonna do to it for good luck. Like you fling it or something. Yes, and if it breaks open, then your wish comes true. We don't know. We don't know. It did leave me down a Google search hole of do people actually eat skunk?
I Googled it too. The first thing that came up was a video of me and Rain and Mary from this scene. Really? Yes. I did a Google video search like on YouTube. You know how they have like people that share about like how they hunt or prepare food or game. Yes. The first thing that came up was the scene from the office. Isn't that crazy? That's not the first thing that came up for me.
Oh, no. The first thing that came up for me was a video of like how to prepare your skunk to eat. I did not watch it, but in the comments, I was able to discern that removing the stink sack is an important element of preparing the skunk. Because it will taint the meat. I'm sure. The smell, the odor.
I read that as well. But people do eat skunk, and it's said that indigenous people ate skunk. I saw the same thing. And that it is an edible thing if you know how to prepare it correctly. That seems very important. I would not trust myself. I know that you can eat the stuff off a cactus, you know, the cactus fruit. And I tried to do that because we have a big cactus in our yard. And we got the cactus fruit on it.
And I tried to prepare it. And I didn't trust that I'd gotten the prickles out. I didn't trust it. I guess I'm just saying I don't trust myself to prepare. Cactus, let alone a skunk. Right. Yeah. So.
I did see one comment that said, there's also plenty of squirrels and rabbits, so I would rather eat that. Like, if you're somewhere where you're hunting skunk, there's probably a squirrel or a rabbit. Anyway. Yeah. Pam is now going to arrive at athlete for her romantic dinner.
No skunk involved here. Jim has champagne. He assumes she got the job. Yeah. And then Pam says, I didn't get it. She doesn't say I chose not to take it. That's right. She says I didn't get it. Jim says, you know what? Hey, you're in Philly. That's still something to celebrate. Yeah. And Pam's ready to settle in to this lovely dinner moment with Jim. And I just want to say that I absolutely loved filming these scenes at Athlead.
We got Jon Favreau all to ourselves. He was so invested in the Jim and Pam storyline, particularly the beats of this dinner and how it was all going to go. He asked me tons of questions. He was very, very interested in making the scenes with us, very layered, very natural. Dave Rogers sent me some pictures of this day
that I had no idea existed. And there are like three pictures of me and Jon Favreau talking that someone took without my knowledge. That's great. And you can just see how concentrated you are. There's one picture where we're shooting, and John Favreau is just looking at me
because I'm the one talking in the scene. Oh my god, I'm going to blow it up and put it on my wall. Frame it. Yes, because there's just this brilliant director, and it just looks like he's hanging on my every word. And I'm like, oh, this is amazing. This is amazing. So I'll give them to you, Angela, so you can share them.
OK. Dang it. No one was there when Rain and I filmed our scene on the front porch. But I had the same experience with John. Rain and I having him all to ourselves for this very intimate moment between Dwight and Angela on the front porch. Well, we're about to get to it right now. Yeah, Dwight walks Angela out to the porch. It's night. I can just, I can feel through the screen that it's one of those just like warm summer evenings, you know, and he thanks her.
And she says it was not an unpleasant way to spend an afternoon. And then they have that moment of silence, which between two people who love each other can very easily end and embrace. It's that moment. He kisses her and she kisses him back. And then Angela stops him and says, no, I can't betray the senator. And Dwight says, this isn't about just like a one time thing. This is about us having a life together. We've already wasted so much time. We belong together. He says he wants to spend his last 80 or 90 years with her. I'm getting goosebumps as you say it, because it's so emotional and vulnerable for Dwight, the character. Yes.
And this is how the character of Angela Martin moves him. And it's, I just loved it. I loved it so much. I did too. And you know, Angela tells him, no, I can't do this. I took a vow. I gave my word. And Dwight said he understands. Stand by your man. That's what he would want if she were his. And she says goodbye Dee and she leaves. I'm getting goose bumps again. I know. And in the shooting draft it said this, Angela leaves Dwight alone under the porch light. He watches her go frustrated but not without admiration. Well, I have gushed about how much I love this scene, but we got a letter from Derek D. in Ontario, Canada, and I thought that Derek said it perfectly.
Okay. Here's what Derek said. I thought this was a beautiful episode that explored both Jam and Duangela at very different crossroads in their respective relationships. They were confronted with what they wanted from each other and what the future could possibly hold and there were no easy answers. The writing was top-notch and your performances were absolutely wonderful." Oh, thank you. And I thought that was absolutely true. You both should win an award just for this porch scene in my opinion. It was beautiful. Jenna, thank you so much.
Mm-hmm. Well, you know, I mean, my gosh, this Jim and Pam scene that's coming up just broke me. It felt so real. You guys really just did such a great job with it. I feel like we have Jon Favreau to thank for that. I really do. I'm really proud of it. We'll get to it. Let's talk about this conference room scene. Yeah, Andy's gonna summon Erin and Pete. They're over by the water cooler talking and he's gonna say, hey, love turds,
into the conference room. Why did they go? I don't know, why is Alice still there? I know, like at this point, just say, okay, something weird's happening here. It's not about me. I'm not going. It's true.
There's no marketing department. There's no job for her to consult on here. Maybe she's just along for the ride at this point. She's like, well, I'm here. Let's see how this plays out. She does seem to revel in her digs at peak. Yeah. So maybe she's like, I'm here for it at this point.
Well, all four exes are going to sit across from each other and discuss their relationship history. There's a lot of animosity. Oh, yes. Alice is going to attack Pete's manhood by making fun of his inability to use chopsticks. And then Gabe is going to beg Erin for one last night together.
Yeah. We had a fan question from Rachel S. in Bloomington, Indiana, who said, I absolutely love this scene in the conference room with all the Xs. I specifically love Gabe's line about wearing Aaron's button downs around the apartment. I would love to know if this line was improvised or scripted. And Maria B. from Montreal said, I
was curious how much of Gabe's dialogue was improvised in this meeting between Andy, Pete, Alice, and Aaron. Well, I'll tell you, Rachel and Maria, in our interview with Jake, he mentioned, first of all, that he had a terrible stomach flu when they shot this scene. I know! That he was literally going to his trailer and puking and then coming back to set. Yeah, he didn't know he could call in sick.
Oh my gosh. And then he also shared that so many of these lines were improvised by Zach Woods. He did improvise the line about wearing Erin's button-downs because the scripted line was, I still have a lock of her hair in my glove compartment, so you could say we still have a relationship of sorts. Yes, apparently Zach did a lot of improvising and did a lot of one-off lines. Like the one where he said he shaved his body as smooth as a porpoise. Well, what's really amazing is how if you follow the script while you're watching the scene, you see the pops that come from Zach Woods, but then the other people take it back to the script.
Yes. And it's so seamless. It's brilliant, especially when I think about Collette being new on our set. And she just rolled with it. She headlines in and around Zach's improv. I thought they all did a great job. At the end of this conference room scene, Andy is a talking head.
And he says, does making Aaron and Pete feel bad make him feel better? Yeah, it does. My gosh, Andy. So snarky, Andy. This is Andy at his snarkiness. At his snarkiest. What'd I say? Ness, snarkiness.
Oh God. I did not have enough tea this morning. All right, here we go. Buckle in because this scene just wrecked me. Pam and Jim are back at Athlead and Pam is actually really going to share her real feelings about coming to Philly. Yeah, she's talking about Mark and they're having a nice dinner. They're eating their Chinese food.
It's kind of flirty. They're reconnecting. Yeah. And then Jim sort of says, you know what, it's all right. The next interview will be better. Yeah. And that's when Pam pauses and says, yeah, I don't want there to be another interview. And then she says she liked their life in Scranton. And Jim is like, well, I started a business in Philly. Yeah, and Pam's like, I'm not sure I want this.
Oh, boy. We got a lot of fan mail about this. I'm gonna start with some practical stuff. Fan question from Andrea F. in Massachusetts and many others pointed out that in the scene that precedes this one, Alice makes that dig about how Pete can't use chopsticks and that shows the scene that precedes this one, Alice makes that dig about how Pete can't use chopsticks and that shows the measure of a man, and then we cut to a scene with Jim expertly using
chopsticks. Oh, I didn't even think of that. People really liked that. Then we got a fan question from Leighton R. in Folsom, California, who just wanted to know, how was the Chinese food? Where did you get it? You know what? I don't know where we got it, but I can tell you this. It was delicious, and it timed out perfectly with lunch. We shot all of the athlete scenes on the same day. We started first thing in the morning with those two scenes that happened
in the first part of the episode of Pam, you know, before her interview. And then we had a little break, and then they reset the stage for these dinner moments. And so we were shooting this in the late morning until about 1 p.m. I just, I remember I was very hungry and the food was very good.
I ate a lot of it. I have noticed that your hunger really dictates how fresh your memories are about things. My personal hunger? Yeah. Oh, you know what? I really do have a lot of food memories. Mm-hmm.
Yeah. Yeah. It's true. I've noticed that's about you. I really enjoy those chocolates. I know. In our friendship, you'll be like, oh, I'll remember that day
because we had gone for a walk and I was so hungry. And then. That's probably true. Then we found that Italian food place, remember? Oh, that's probably true. So I'll tell you, when we finished shooting this scene on this day, we had a big visit from the Television Critics Association. That's right.
We talked about it last week. It was on the call sheet. It was. And we all gathered in the warehouse and Ed and Brian and Craig formed a band and they played music. And then we had this big Q&A session with them and Greg was there. And this was all our way of kind of schmoozing the television critics about the final episodes of The
Office. We wanted to give them kind of like the inside scoop. The sneak peek. Mm-hmm. I don't think it hurt that Jon Favreau was there that day. Probably didn't. Angela, I saw on the call sheet that you were off that day, but you had to come in and do your hair and makeup for the TCAs.
That was true for pretty much everyone because Jon and I were the only ones shooting that day. Yeah, and I had to come in for the table read. Which was after that. Yeah. There were a lot of moving parts that day. Yeah, and I had to come in for the table read. Which was after that. Yeah. There were a lot of moving parts that day. I would like to also share with you all that in the shooting draft of Moving On,
差不多所有人都是这样，因为那天只有我和乔恩在拍摄。是的，我得来参加剧本围读。那是拍摄之后的事。对。那天有很多杂事。是的，我得来参加剧本围读。那是拍摄之后的事。对。那天有很多杂事。我还想告诉大家，在《继续前进》的拍摄剧本中，
the episode would have ended with this Jim and Pam final scene. This would have been like the cliffhanger. Yes, and I am glad that it didn't because it is really sad and tense. And I'm glad we end with a more uplifting moment and then also such a big tease. Yes. Well, let's get into it. This is something that we shot again for couples discount.
这一集本应以吉姆和帕姆的最后这个场景结束。这本来会是一个悬念。是的，我很高兴它没有那样拍，因为那真的很伤感、很紧张。我很高兴我们以一个更振奋人心的时刻结束，而且还有一个这么大的伏笔。是的。好吧，我们开始吧。这是我们为《情侣折扣》重新拍摄的片段。
Yep. This would have been the cold open of couples discount, but it has now become the tag of moving on. That's right. Oscar's at his computer. He's watching Hobbies of the East. And when a commercial break comes on, he goes over to this chin-up bar that he has installed. Yeah.
没错。这本来会是《情侣折扣》的冷开场，但现在成了《继续前进》的片尾彩蛋。没错。奥斯卡坐在电脑前。他在看《东方风情》。当广告插播时，他走向他安装的引体向上杆。对。
It looks like he was watching women play Marjan. Yeah. And we find something out that really cracked me up, Jenna, especially with everything you shared last week about your online purchases, is that Oscar, he watches too many online ads and he doesn't do enough sit-ups. So he bought ankle braces, which by the way, he bought from an online ad, so he can get 30 seconds of ad blasting whenever an ad pops up. Ads for abs.
看起来他当时在看女人打麻将。对。我们发现了一件让我大笑不已的事，珍娜，尤其是结合你上周分享的那些网购经历——奥斯卡看了太多网购广告，却做仰卧起做不够。所以他买了一些护踝，顺便说一句，他是从网络广告里买的，这样每当广告弹出来时，他就能享受30秒的广告轰炸。为了腹肌的广告。
Well, this contraption is real and Oscar did it. He goes over and he hooks himself in upside down and starts doing some crunches. Meanwhile, Angela and Phyllis are pushing him aside to get in and out of the kitchen. Yes, it was really fun to walk past him with just like my cup of coffee. Like, excuse me. Well, we got a few fan questions, one from Ivy Kay in Harrisonburg, Virginia, who said, how long did Oscar have to hang from the sit-up contraption and were there any safety meetings involved? And another one from Sage L in Kitchener, Ontario, Canada, who said, in the button with Oscar,
好吧，这个玩意儿是真的，奥斯卡也真的用了。他走过去，把自己倒挂在上面，开始做卷腹。与此同时，安吉拉和菲利斯把他推到一边，以便进出厨房。是的，手里拿着一杯咖啡从他身边走过真的很有趣。就像，不好意思。好吧，我们收到了几个粉丝的问题，其中一个来自弗吉尼亚州哈里森堡的艾薇·K，她问：奥斯卡在那个仰卧起坐器械上挂了多久？其中有没有涉及安全会议？另一个来自加拿大安大略省基奇纳的萨奇·L，他说：在奥斯卡的那个彩蛋里，
is that really him doing the sit ups? Well, we knew we would have to ask Oscar about this, and he sent in an audio clip. Here's what he had to say. Hi, Angela. Hi, Jenna. Let's see. Was that me really hanging?
真的是他在做仰卧起坐吗？好吧，我们知道我们得问问奥斯卡这件事，他发来了一段音频。听听他是怎么说的。嗨，安吉拉。嗨，珍娜。让我想想。真的是我在上面挂着吗？
And did we have safety meetings? And was that me doing sit ups? Yes to all of that. I don't remember. I remember doing the scene. I don't remember, I remember doing the scene. I don't remember exactly what happened before and after, because it was just a regular day. It was a day on the set, which is a kind of a normal day. It was a long time ago. And so, I'm sure we had a safety meeting and they said, Oscar, do you think you can do this? I remember thinking, oh, this is like that scene in American Gigolo when Richard Gere
我们开过安全会议吗？真的是我在做仰卧起坐吗？这些答案都是肯定的。我不记得了。我记得拍那个场景。我不记得了，我记得拍那个场景。我不记得之前和之后具体发生了什么，因为那只是普通的一天。那是片场平凡的一天，可以说是很正常的一天。那是很久以前的事了。所以，我确信我们开过安全会议，他们说，奥斯卡，你觉得你能行吗？我记得当时我想，哦，这就像《美国舞男》里理查·基尔
hangs upside down. This is a movie from the 80s, I think. Had that song, Call Me, with Blondie. But anyway, so I'm sure they said, hey, can you do this? And I said, yes. I don't think there was a stunt person there. They probably offered one to me. So I hung.
倒挂的那场戏。我想那是部80年代的电影。里面有布朗迪乐队的歌《Call Me》。不管怎样，所以我确信他们说过，嘿，你能行吗？我说，行。我觉得那里没有替人特技。他们可能给我提供过。所以我挂上去了。
And at the beginning, it was easy to do the sit ups. As it went on the scene more takes you get more and more tired. But I think I was okay. Maybe towards the end I needed help getting up towards the bar. I think that might have happened towards the end. But I remember there were a lot of funny takes. My wife reminded me of the one where she looked at it where Angela walks by and pushes me aside like I'm a curtain hanging there. But that was me.
一开始，做仰卧起坐很容易。随着拍摄的进行，拍的条数越多，你就会越来越累。但我觉得我还行。也许快结束时，我需要人帮忙才能够到那个单杠。我想快结束时可能发生过这种情况。但我记得有很多搞笑的镜头。我妻子提醒过我其中一个镜头，安吉拉走过去把我推开，就像我是一块挂在那里的窗帘一样。但那确实是我。
There were no stunt people used for that. It wasn't that dangerous. It was just a weird scene that we did at the office. I remember his face getting red. Well, it's funny you say that because Steve Burgess sent me the test videos. And it was Tim from construction and John from special effects. They put in the bar and they tested it and Tim hooked himself in and he's hanging upside down. And they're like, hey, man, is the blood rushing to your head? And he's like, it is.
没有替身演员参与那场戏。没那么危险。那只是我们在办公室拍的一个奇怪的场景。我记得他的脸变红了。好吧，你这么说真搞笑，因为史蒂夫·伯吉斯把测试视频发给了我。那是道具组的蒂姆和特效组的约翰。他们装好单杠并进行了测试，蒂姆把自己挂上去，倒挂着。他们问，嘿，伙计，血是不是都涌到头上去了？他回答说是的。
Yeah. And he was like, it's pretty easy to get in and out of, but it was really hard to do the crunches. But and they even practice the bit where they kind of like push them aside to be like you or Phyllis. So yeah, they did an extensive test. I did notice that Phyllis is like, I have hot coffee here, but she was holding her hand around the mug, not using the handles. Yes, and then when she hands it to Stanley, he reacts as if it's super hot. Yeah, I know. Well after all this business of hanging upside down, the camera goes back to Oscar's computer
对。他说，上下去挺容易，但要做卷腹真的很难。而且他们甚至练习了那种把他们推开的动作，假装是你或者菲利斯。所以，是的，他们做了广泛的测试。我注意到菲利斯说，我这里有热咖啡，但她是用手握着马克杯周围，而不是用把手。是的，当她把它递给斯坦利时，他的反应好像这咖啡烫极了。对，我知道。好吧，在倒挂这档子事之后，镜头切回了奥斯卡的电脑
and we see an ad pop up. And it says, coming this May, the office, an American workplace, 10 years in the making, a look at the lives and loves of an average American small business office. And that's what the episode ends with! My gosh. Well, I remember after that aired, all of our phones blowing up. People were like, oh my gosh!
我们看到一个广告弹出来。上面写着：今年五月即将上演，《办公室》，一部美国职场剧，历时10年打造，聚焦普通美国小企业办公室的生活与爱恨。这一集就在这里结束！天哪。好吧，我记得那一集播出后，我们所有人的电话都被打爆了。大家都在说，哦天哪！
Yeah. Well, listen, oh my gosh. Yeah. Well, listen, before we go today, I wanted to read a letter that we got from Amy A. in Bakersfield, California. It's very emotional, but I was very moved by it. And I wanted to read it. Yeah. So here we go.
是的。听着，哦天哪。是的。听着，在我们今天离开之前，我想读一封我们收到的信，发件人是加利福尼亚州贝克斯菲尔德的艾米·A。这非常感人，但我被深深打动了。我想读一下。好的，我们开始。
Angela and Jenna, I don't have a question, but just some words of gratitude. On November 22nd, 2023, I lost my husband, Zach, suddenly at the age of 38. For the next few months, I sulked and cried and couldn't really get out of bed. We spent 15 years together and I didn't know what adult life was like without him guiding our ship. On Valentine's Day this year, I decided to watch our office anniversary episode, Moving On.
安吉拉和珍娜，我没有什么问题，只想表达一些感激之情。2023年11月22日，我的丈夫扎克突然离世，年仅38岁。在接下来的几个月里，我郁郁寡欢，泪流满面，甚至无法真正下床。我们一起度过了15年，我不知道没有他掌舵的成年生活会是什么样。今年情人节，我决定观看我们的办公室周年纪念集《继续前进》。
This was the first episode of The Office we ever watched together, and we found it by accident because we were both sick February 14th, 2013, when the episode first aired, and all we wanted to do was have soup and bed. Sorry. After that episode, we were hooked. We were office fans together and often quizzed each
这是我们一起看的第一集《办公室》，我们是偶然发现它的，因为在2013年2月14日这一集首播时我们都生病了，而我们只想喝着汤躺在床上。抱歉。看完那一集后，我们就彻底迷上了。我们是一起看《办公室》的粉丝，经常在午休时互相出题考对方，还不断引用剧中的台词。由于他的离世，我落下了你们的播客节目，直到上周一重返工作岗位后才重新开始听。我在开车回家的路上放声大哭，因为你们的声音、你们的故事，还有对这部剧的回忆，把我瞬间拉回了与他在一起的时光。日子依然很难熬，但在家里播放你们的播客——那里我丈夫的气息依然非常浓厚——给了我极大的平静。看着《办公室》并回想起我们所有的内部笑话，让我露出了微笑。我会将我们对《办公室》的共同热爱永远铭记在心，每次看一集时，我都会笑，可能
other during our lunch breaks and quoted lines to each other constantly. Because of his passing, I fell behind on your podcast episodes and began listening again last Monday after returning to work. I bawled on my drive home because your voices, your stories, and just memories of the show took me right back to my time with him. The days are still very hard, but having your podcast on in my home, where my husband's presence is still very strong, gives me so much peace. Watching The Office and remembering all of our inside jokes together makes me smile. I will carry our mutual love of The Office with me forever, and I will laugh and probably
也会哭。谢谢你们把一些欢笑带回我的生活。扎克也会感激的。充满感激之情，艾米。艾米，非常感谢你写信来。你知道，真的很难用言语来表达，《办公室》这部剧能帮助人们度过这样的艰难时期，或者帮助人们建立连接、疗愈，这对我们有多么重要。最重要的是，珍娜和我现在以某种方式参与其中，
also cry every time I watch an episode. Thank you both for bringing some laughter back into my life. Zach would be grateful too, with so much gratitude, Amy. Amy, thank you so much for writing in. You know, it's really just hard to put into words how much it means to us that the office as a show helps people through times like this or helps people connect or heal. And then on top of it, that in any way that Jen and I are a part of that now
通过播客陪伴着你。我们只想把爱送给你，把你放在我们心中。是的。谢谢你让我们能陪伴着你。是的。我们爱你们。我们爱你们。我们爱你们大家。我们非常喜欢做这个节目。而且我确实想让大家知道，自从我们在节目早期和克里德通话后，他又给我们发了一次短信。
with the podcast, to be there for you. We just want to give you our love and we just hold you in our hearts. Yeah. Thanks for letting us be there with you. Yeah. We love you. We love you. We love you guys. We love doing this. And I do want you all to know that Creed texted us one last time since we spoke to him earlier in the episode.
我想把刚刚收到的短信读给大家听。这是一首美丽的诗。确实是。克里德写道，既然今天早上这么有缘，我想把艾伦·沃茨关于猫的我最喜欢的名言发给你们。当一只猫从树上掉下来时，它会彻底放松自己。猫会变得完全放松，轻盈地落在地上。但是，如果一只猫要从树上掉下来，却突然下定决心不想掉下去，它就会变得紧张、僵硬，落地时就会变成
And I wanted to read you the text he just sent us. It's a beautiful poem. It is. Creed wrote, since this morning has been so serendipitous, I thought I'd send you my favorite cat quote from Alan Watts. When a cat falls out of a tree, it lets go of itself. The cat becomes completely relaxed and lands lightly on the ground. But if a cat were about to fall out of a tree and suddenly make up its mind that it didn't want to fall, it would become tense and rigid and would be just a bag of broken bones upon
一袋碎骨头。同样的道理，道家哲学认为，在我们生命的每一刻，我们其实都在从树上掉下来。事实上，从我们出生那一刻起，我们就从悬崖上被踢了下来，我们在坠落，没有什么能阻止它。所以，与其生活在长期的紧张状态中，并紧紧抓住那些实际上在和我们一起下坠的各种事物（因为整个世界都是无常的），不如像一只猫那样。我太喜欢了。好吧，非常感谢雷恩·威尔逊、奥斯卡·努涅斯、戴夫·罗杰斯、史蒂夫·伯吉斯和克里德·布拉顿
landing. In the same way, it is the philosophy of the Tao that we are all falling off a tree at every moment of our lives. As a matter of fact, the moment we were born, we were kicked off a precipice and we are falling and there is nothing that can stop it. So instead of living in a state of chronic tension and clinging to all sorts of things that are actually falling with us because the whole world is impermanent, be like a cat. I love it. Well, a big thank you to Rainn Wilson, Oscar Nunez, Dave Rogers, Steve Burgess, and Creed Bratton
为这一集增添光彩，也谢谢你们所有人。感谢你们来信，发送你们的问题、评论和信件。我们太爱你们了。现在我们要播放一点克里德的新单曲，现已上线，名为《转过宇宙的拐角》。下周我们将带来对鲍勃·奥登科克的采访，不见不散。又是一个与其他日子相同的日子，结果会怎样呢我们的怀疑正在消退，我们不买账那些炒作互不偷窃，我们紧密维系着我们的家庭当我们转过宇宙的拐角。星球正在冷却。
for brightening up this episode and to all of you. For writing in, sending your questions, your comments, and letters. We love you so much. And now we are going to play a little bit of Creed's new single, Out Now, Turn the Corner of the Universe. And we'll see you next week with our interview with Bob Odenkirk. Another day just like the others, how it might turn out to be Our doubt is in remission, we don't buy into the hype No stealing from each other, we keep our family tight when we turn the corner of the universe. The planet's cooling down.
所有的努力都有了回报。我们不会倒下。我们不会倒下。我们不会走这条路的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是乔丹·达菲，助理制作人是艾斯利·巴巴科。
All the hard work is paying off. We won't go down. We won't go down. We won't go down this route. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.